via many victims of war are living next
to a graveyard 1000 kilometers from
their homes fighting forced them to move
south from herida province - Aidan but
now they face a different threat poverty
and hunger they don't have the money to
pay for the most basic commodities we
consist of 11 families who have flared
Alger Aki we have found no shelter
except this graveyard
we are scattered between graves as we
cannot be her hot shelter Hamid sells
empty plastic bottles which he collects
from the streets he says it's the only
way he can even attempt to provide his
big family most days we eat from
leftover food in the garbage I work all
day to collect plastic bottles on the
best days I end up with 1 or 2 dollars
so we asked for blankets and regular
food aid the United Nations says more
than 2 million many families have left
their homes since the war began in March
2015
here in sana the suffering of people who
had being displaced from their homes
he's as great as those in Adan across
the country foreign help has failed to
supply enough aid to those who need it
most
four years of war has led to a critical
shortage of all basic essentials Shalit
fled the fighting inhalator for summer
in his family have taken over this long
deserted house his son is an oppression
to see his right eye but there is no
money I fled the war in her data as the
situation there has become unbearable
especially after I lost my work I've
also come here to treat my son before he
loses his sight but I have ended up with
no work and with no hope for a better
future as the fighting inhalator goes on
despite a ceasefire that was signed last
December more civilians are likely to be
forced from their homes in search of
safety and food
and his family's long journey has
brought them to his previa but they
don't know how they will survive over
the coming months I'm not Bob aljazeera